she wants Malaysia's government to
finally see her pain for 10 days this
woman has feared the worst for her son
hoping every day for any message for
certainty however before the Transport
Minister arrives to take questions she
is forced out of the room the minister
is clearly on the defensive now it's not
just the family members who are calling
the investigation unprofessional and
lacking and transparency there's new
information six weeks ago the pilot
deleted flight simulator files from his
computer authorities hope to recover
these to see if he practiced any unusual
routes and checks have been performed on
almost all passengers receive messages
background checks from all countries
apart from Ukraine and Russia both of
which had national support so far no
information of significance on any
messages has been found authorities are
calling the international cooperation in
the search effort unprecedented but the
search effort faces daunting challenges
with the plane potentially anywhere
within a radius of 4,000 kilometers the
focus is on two corridors investigators
are now paying particular attention to
the Southern Corridor in the Indian
Ocean 26 countries are taking part in
the search for the missing Boeing and
China has now deployed its most modern
ship the rescue cutter hi Shawn 01 it's
also meant to show that at least China
is doing all it can